this is the
switch that has to happen and this
mess with the schools is waking up a lot
of dems to the fact that look
um
this should not be as ideological as it
is i mean one thing that bill maher just
put out that you just sent me yeah was
that democrats dramatically overestimate
the chances of kovid putting you in the
hospital and it's not like you know the
actual number is one to five percent
right yeah some of that um but it's not
like we think 20 of the people are dying
it's they think like 50 plus percent of
people are dying and 70 of the party
thinks it's over 20
of people are dying yeah so so this to
me has to be that the message that these
moms are finding out yeah is that the
democrats imagine
that they're the party of facts
and science
uh and then the republicans are
uh troglodytes and you know like
ignorant and the rest of it um but then
when you start digging it turns out that
the democrats are actually tribal
uh and ideological
in the same way as anyone else and
that's not a knock it's just you know
everyone's somewhat tribal but then if
someone like this mom in cleveland raise
their hand and be like hey i'm a member
of the tribe and like you know these
facts aren't lining up then they just
get hammered down like instead of you
know so like because then they'll be
like hey turns out you're not on our
team or what not yes and there are all
these people embedded within the
democratic party who actually have
similar points of view who fear the
hammering down they know if they say
these things and that's what we're going
to get to now
which is
um your experience as someone who is
something of a convert to the democratic
party that there is a sense that some
people
some people's experiences are more valid
than others if you are
let's say in your case like a straight
white dude or in this author's case like
a white mom
then you're not allowed to criticize or
talk and that if you do
then you're going to be personally
attacked it's a really deep point and
it's it's it's just she's thought where
do you go right and the challenge is
on the presidential level which a lot of
us
we hold a president is a different
election right we hold them as like
almost god-like essentially in terms of
our leaders and what we look up to and
blame things on and that's
a lot of like research on that too it's
it's a combination of whether it's
virtue signaling or
the right mouth piece um in terms of
who can say what and what can be said
and i'm curious your thoughts on this
because my hesitation of ever getting
into politics is that i'm like socially
aligned with democrats i think the
democrats generally have the right
policies on a lot of things some things
on the republican side i think you know
i like capitalism more than um
i do socialism or other socialism or
other things but um
i've hesitated because i don't think the
democratic party loves straight white
men
um and even when i was telling talking
to you about running
before like before i met you when we
first started i was like how do you beat
donald trump
i was like thinking i had to be an
outsider i had to be someone who was
young i thought they had to be male i
thought they had to have the
balance to the trump male energy but i
also thought they had to be diverse
coming from the democratic party to get
through that primary you've talked about
this a bit with john mcwhorter but why
are democrats we're obsessed with
identity i have some thoughts on it too
but we care a lot about the messenger
over the message at times you lived that
i think
both the pros and cons of that john
described it in his book awoke racism
which you should check out and check out
my convo with with john
if you haven't seen it he says that
there's a certain subset of the
democratic party that is
obsessed
with the power differential
um so the power differential typically
is framed as white black or whites have
the power blacks do not and so whites
need to uh try and address this through
various behaviors that john argues don't
actually address the fundamental
problems that people care about it's
just you know sort of a strange
behavioral layer but the other power
differentials that people are concerned
about um are male female straight part
of the lgbtq yeah right yes and so
taking a figure like you um you are
all of the quote unquote like uh
positives and the power differentials
because you're a straight white male
also in your case uh you have the sins
of being tall
handsome
[Laughter]
i'm the devil incarnate the rest of it
so
if you frame everything in power
differential then it's like well someone
like you
then any success you achieve is uh
because
you are who you are and it had nothing
to do with your
uh actions character or work ethic like
you know
it's just you know you just fell out of
bedroom right yeah
and are super successful
um and
the asian guy
um occupies like a nebulous place in
this uh in this framework because if you
look at andrew yang you think okay
um straight male
asian
and then you're like where are asians in
the
power differential right um and the
answer is
it is whatever is convenient to you
minority behind the scenes but now we're
putting in front of the scenes if we can
but the asians are known as a convenient
minority in democratic politics so
they're not a minority when they want
some message and they are
people of color when they uh
when it's politically convenient yeah so
i was interested obviously as a
candidate how it would be received um
and i think that it turns out that um
that the quote-unquote benefits of being
a minority
um did not include
me
like there wasn't this like oh like you
know look what this person must have
overcome as a son of immigrants like
that that stuff all went out the window
which i'm
more or less cool with and i think a lot
of it too is the persona i have which is
i'm not someone who
is going to be leading with like look at
all the [ __ ] i've overcome kind of stuff
like that that's not my jam i'm more
like okay let's get [ __ ] done you know
let's uh
operate um and one of the major reasons
why i wouldn't fall into the negative
side of this power differential the like
less powerful side right is because uh
the
perception was like well he's a business
guy he's a tech bro he's uh this or that
but but to your point in the
presidential primary we've discussed
this yeah there were half a dozen or
more
straight wine men who ran that never got
the time of day in the presidential race
many of whom
we spoke with personally you and i and
we liked and thought well of and thought
would make fine presidents
one guy who completely got short shift
uh joe sesdak yeah great guy press
completely ignored him people watching
this right now are like who yeah you
look up uh joe sasdak um michael bennett
great guy
uh john hickenlooper the one i thought
that actually had the full package was
john hickenlooper where that he was an
entrepreneur
uh he started what's the goose island
beer whatever the beer company is um
ran it himself and then became governor
like has business political experience
um
and real and actually is
like there were some and i'm gonna leave
them nameless not fair but there were
plenty of
where i'm at like the world doesn't
we're not clamoring for more straight
white dudes in politics like we have
that voice we have that perspective
right i'm not that's not the problem
well this to me is one of the dangers
good is that if you look at the straight
white dudes in politics uh the media
organizations of the democratic side do
not want to elevate
this set of figures yes they
will accept like the folks who are
already kind of you know emblazoned in
the public consciousness like uh bernie
or joe right but and why is that you
think is it because of
representation
yeah
there's a there's a fixation
there's a fixation on
um trying to address the power
differential and wouldn't it be great if
we got the first
x of y right uh now there are a lot of
americans who are kind of impatient with
the first x of y thing
um because it doesn't matter as much as
we thought or hoped or whatever the hell
right um you know there were some people
that thought barack obama present united
states means we're not racist anymore
we're post-racial which by the way we're
probably more racist now than we were
backfired people could you know people
were making the same argument um about
hillary it's like hey first of all
president we like show that we all be
over it and then uh you know like uh um
i i don't think that would have fixed it
like like that imagine systemic problems
right
imagining that that having an elected
representative of a certain identity and
by the way like i'm for people of
different backgrounds being in
like different seats i mean i i think i
think it's great but but making that
like the
criteria
the criterion that you're using
primarily is is not great and
a lot of americans can sense that the
media in particular has gone overboard
with this
and one of the byproducts of this is
that it has the potential to
divide the country further
where you have and i'm going to use you
as the proxy
you have like reasonable well-intended
white people men and women who are
generally aligned with the democratic
party on some things but feel driven out
because there's this implicit like we
don't care about you and your
perspective because you are the powerful
in the power differential equation and
all we're going to do is talk to people
who are from an historically
marginalized group because we i live
this both personally and through you
right on this campaign but also um i
want to share this with everybody we
live this actually with each other i
don't know if you remember this story um
it was really early on i just started on
a campaign and i was
we'd go into like our first couple
meetings and i'd make these little
one-off comments i didn't even realize i
was making i'd be like
uh we'd talk about your campaign or i'd
talk about the campaign and be like well
that's if we if we do okay or that's
before we get a real campaign manager we
get a real xyz or like kind of caveat
what we were doing
and you
got really mad and in my opinion
justifiably so you're like stop
second guessing this caveatting like we
got to go in guns blazing we are
confident we're setting the world on
fire this is a vision we have to get
people on board we can't give them crap
show the cracks in our in our faith in
this because we don't believe how
they're going to believe which is
logical
but and then it got to a point where i
was really like proactively working on
it and i was still [ __ ] it up like
you and you would notice it make you
more mad you're like i've asked you six
times to do this and i remember i sat
you down probably like it took me a
while figured i'm like dude here's the
deal
my whole life
i naturally come at it
trying to be as humble as humanly
possible when i go to a meeting because
i come off as a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know look at this [ __ ] look at this
yeah [ __ ] um who's where'd he go
dude
[ __ ] that like that that's right and so
like and you but then you told me like
and i was like i think for you having
watching you like
and this is [ __ ] up too but like as an
asian guy people think you're timid or
shy or not not sure of yourself and
gonna stand there quietly and let people
walk over you which is a [ __ ]
stereotype so you go the opposite you're
like bang extreme and when you have if
you say the same thing that i would say
it comes off 10 times different and i've
learned that
the hard way because one time in ohio i
gave your stump speech at like a
democratic event like the basically word
for word stump awful question burned
could not do it the opposite of donald
trump is an asian guy who likes math
doesn't sound as cool
it sounds a little offensive coming from
me
did not go well um
identity matters um and like and um i'm
not there's systems around us that are
creating those perceptions and realities
did you feel the need to be more
confident in yourself and your vision
because you were asian or was that
something you had growing up to or
something you felt more in politics some
thoughts on on that piece well certainly
on the campaign front people i knew were
going to take their cues from us and so
if i come in and people like oh he's not
serious then you know they're not going
to tell their friends because they're
like this isn't going to go anywhere in
terms of my upbringing and the rest of
it um i was one of the only
asian kids in my public school
uh so i felt like my masculinity was in
question all the time i'd also skipped a
grade so that made it shorter i was like
scrawnier and shorter and like that the
rest of it uh i had a chip on my
shoulder i got in a lot of fights as a
kid um and so then when i i lost most of
them and then when
i got to like age 17 i started going to
the gym
and so i became like an angry
weightlifting asian guy who drank
protein shakes and the rest of it yeah
you know these guys yeah if you went to
the bro yeah spot you bro and you went
if you went to the i liked them they
played basketball mostly too yes okay i
you know i did that
and so was that in some ways a response
to
challenges to my masculinity growing up
a hundred percent yeah it's a phenomenon
that a lot of
asian guys are familiar with or if you
go to the gym you see the the asian
dudes
were
i'm very and we can do a whole episode
of this i'm very very passionate about
um manhood and understanding
um
i think most of the some of the biggest
problems in our society are caused by
weak men insecure men like if you want
you want to help women like like helping
men be less shitty is a really good way
to which place to start frankly because
a lot right um what men go through as
kids is uh like in how they define their
masculine he's a big part of that i did
musicals right so i had to do sports to
balance that out because i like to sing
i like to play saxophone you better do
some sports though but i had you right
and then i didn't fit in either right so
here's i've never said this out loud but
i'm i'm curious it's like if there's a
acceptance in the democratic party that
the straight white male is the
root of all evil and power like that's
the bastion of uh there's a subset of
the democratic party that would agree
with that right right that's that's the
problem right
i don't i don't know if vilifying all of
them is the right strategy i'm going to
say it's the wrong strategy
[Music]
you